just read a an article by Michael Heiser
on um on basically the uh evolutionary
theory in Genesis and he was basically
saying there's no contradiction there's
no problem with it no that's that was
his opinion I I could care I know he's
with the Lord now no that's his him
capitulating with with science
because they're trying to make Genesis
compatible with the theories of macro
Evolution and this is why so many
scholars are dangerous like just like
William Lane Craig that heretic now
wants to argue that Genesis is I was
going to bring him up mythistory and
that Adam and Eve was selected from a
group of beings that are prior to what
did he say I just played the clip I
don't want to misrepresent him I think
he said prior to Homo sapiens that's
because they are capitulating to the
world they're whing themselves for the
world because they bought into these
theories and want to make Genesis
compatible with those views no that's
that's garbage but go ahead got you so
yeah my question was I I I had heard
before that case and I watched a debate
with um inspiring philosophy yeah um
Michael Jones and Dr Marcus Ross because
inspir philosophy is heavily influenced
by scholarship like William Han cek yes
and uh John Walden and Michael Heiser he
is who he cites a lot you know um but
anyway they were saying he was basically
in the in the debate making the case
that there there was death before sin
due to okay even if I grant that that
death entered there's a form of death
like plant life right okay what does
that got to do with Adam and Eve being
created from the dust because you have
old Earth creationists who believe Adam
was created from dust and Eve was
created from his side that do believe
there was some form of death that
occurred prior to the sin of Adam Eve
because Adam sin brought death to
mankind they'll say but there was some
type of death that was already occurring
in the world such as plant life you
would have to eat the plants and that's
a form of death right yeah okay so
what's the problem how does that then
all of a sudden go from yeah there was
some type of kind of death taking place
to then Adam and Eve being mytho history
so that when the Bible says Adam and Eve
were created the way God created them
man from dust Eve from his side that's
more mythical than historical though
there was an Adam and Eve they were not
really created that way how do you get
from one to the
other yeah that that's a good point
there is a jump there and then be beyond
that do you believe that the serpent
being the devil was already in sin prior
to Adam and Eve sinning yep they have
well they have to right yeah yeah
because who was their original
sinner the Satan yeah so that means
death already existed before Adam and
Eve because the soul that sin shall die
so if Satan sinned he already died
before Adam and Eve did right yeah yeah
okay so what's the problem yeah that's a
good point I hadn't really thought about
that Sam that's a great point right yeah
yeah 100% 100% that that would be the
original yeah because if if Satan was
the original sinner who sinned and
rebelled before Adam and Eve that means
the soul that sin shall die he had
already sinned and therefore experienced
death before Adam and Eve yeah
H I can't believe I had never thought
about that you might be better looking
than me but not smarter than me
sir okay so then yeah that none of those
views will then make the leap of logic
from saying oh well then Mac Revolution
is true and therefore the Bible is not
meant to give you history and therefore
we can argue that Adam and Eve though
they may have existed were not created
the way Genesis said they were created
because that's mythistory who in the
history of the church argued that Adam
and Eve were not created in the way that
God created them yeah as far as I days I
know the days have been argued you can
find fathers who say that the days of
Genesis are thousands of years so that a
day equals a thousand year and they base
this on Psalm 90 verse4 and 2 Peter
38 that you can argue that the days are
not solar days from the church fathers
but I want them to quote Christians
prior to post Enlightenment or
evolutionary theory saying that Adam was
not created from the dust and Eve
created from the side of Adam the way
the Bible
teaches yeah okay and those were kind of
my questions Sam I was just kind of
looking for you know your general
approach to that topic um uh just some
kind of pointers to kind of push to lead
me into that
um be because I know I there that Gavin
Orton I believe except theistic
Evolution um yeah he did a video on why
Augustin he thought would be open to
Augustin Augustine is the odd man out
even with Augustine where they say well
because William Lan Craig isn't an
ironic they look to Augustine poor
Augustine gets a bad rap for everything
for every Protestant heresy you blame
Augustine Calvinism you blame Augustine
no
serious
a he's the odd man out even with
Augustine I want them to show me where
Augustine said Adam and Eve were not
created the way Genesis says because
they will appeal to Augustine saying
that the days of Genesis need not be
literal but they can simply be a poetic
way of describing creation and that God
already put within creation certain
potencies that would unfold throughout
time because that's William Lan Craig's
argument but I want them to show me if
it's there I'll be corrected I'll accept
correction where Augustine did not think
Adam was created from the dust and Eve
from the side but Augustine is the
Boogeyman who gets attacked in a bad rep
for all these heresies of the
Protestants from
Calvinism to Lutheranism because of his
view of predestination to now Genesis so
how convenient they single out Augustine
what about the people before Augustine
after Augustine let's forget they
existed why Augustin conveniently
Augustin huh so forget aanas forget
novatian forget cians martyr
yeah they they don't exist because
Augustine is a scapegoat so that you
don't condemn them for being Heretics
yeah that's true they're disgusting when
people keep appealing to Augustine man
anyway and you're right he he he does
get appealed to even especially by
Calvinists oh yeah because Luther and
Calvin Even Calvin is quoted I read him
in one of the books he's saying that
that he sees himself so much in
Augustine that Augustine's so much in
him that if you read Augustine you're
reading Calvin
Augustine after his debate with
Pelagius started adopting a harder form
of predestination that he inherited from
his manism but he was the odd manat
because the church unanimously before
and even after and
consensus condemned hardcore
predestination and affirmed that God
endowed man with the ability to choose
Christ or reject but Augustin again is
the odd man out and when he disagrees
with the consensus of the church or the
plain reading of the text that's his
opinion yeah but they make him the
standard because they want to find a
scapegoat John Calvin and Luther found
it in Augustine William L Craig the
heretic finds it in Augustine poor
Augustin dude he gets a bad rep for
everything I saw that clip from uh Leon
flowers and D Dr David Allen discussing
that the manans used the same verses as
the Calvinists in fact John chrism you
know what he says in John
644 what I quoted it John chrism and his
commentary in John 644 says the
manans misused this passage to teach
hardcore predestination wow let me show
it to you here that's amazing here let
me get it to you because you know you
know it is
people manin are gnostics really but
mannequin were gnostics but here let me
show it to you I'll put it right here on
the board yeah these guys and poor poor
Augustine man dude augus You' got a bad
rap that's why people hate you so much
everyone says that the Catholic Church
ched with you Augustine Augustine here
let me see where's John Dear John all
right what he says about John 644 here
it is guys John cistem writing in the
4th Century who interpreted John 644
like Calvinists here it is Hy
46 Hy 46 who interpreted John 6:44 like
Calvinists the church Universal or
gnostics here you
go let me show
you let me find it for you all
right the man right here John
644 okay here he goes guys who butchered
John
644 to teach hardcore predestination
like Calvinists do was it the church
Universal or the man Heretics here it is
guys word for word John 6:44 the manans
spring upon these words saying that
nothing lies in our own power what does
that sound like wow
wow that's amazing what your John 644
like that false Bible butcher Jamal
Muhammad white and Antonio Dodgers to
teach man's inability to choose Christ
unless God has already chosen
you wow according to John cstem who was
doing that the church or Manan Heretics
Gnostic
Heretics what does it say crazy yeah and
because remember Augustin was a Manan
and to respond to pagus he reverted back
to the Manan Distortion of scripture
where they try to marry Christianity
with their Gnostic hardcore
predeterminism and sadly he reverted
back to that understanding and founded
everyone's scripture whereas the church
universally condemned that and rebuked
manans for butchering scripture to say
that and even after August
wow that's amazing Sam and here yeah let
me get you the link so you can read it
John 644 there is so you guys got it
everyone of you any other followup
questions brother um uh no just real
quick on and praise as me to Jesus that
uh PA V uh con converted to uh to the
ancient Church Paul uh van uh I I can't
pronounce his last name I can't even
don't know who was it yeah Paul vandery
or something like that something like
that
it was uh Warren MCU who was with Warren
MC oh oh him he became or yeah oh that
guy yeah I'm like who you're talking
about yeah according to orth Christos
Paul vandi I think yeah you're right
yeah guys responding to Mike Winger he
became Orthodox I didn't know that but
glory to God praise God like that's
amazing listen to Matt Powell destroying
macro Revolution using scientific facts
and go to Roberts and Jenis where he
tells you that the church historically
even though he's Catholic the church
would have been the church fathers that
the Orthodox accept taught
Adam and Eve special creation and that
Genesis gives you an actual history of
how God created the universe and how the
facts of science destroys micro
Evolution so luk for Roberts and Jenis
don't let these Protestants and even
Catholics sadly sadly Catholics you have
now Cardinals and Priests saying that
macro evolution is compatible with
Catholicism Roberts and Jenna says no
that's a lie it's not and I thank God
for voices like Roberts and jennis who
shows you what the Catholic church has
historically taught and not capitulating
to Modern views that are not even
scientific facts there are still views
that are being
revised darwinian evolution is not the
evolution taught today it's been revised
so much that they disassociate Evolution
with DAR Darwin's view of evolution
because they're not the same because
they had to revise it and re- revise it
to make it fit with the fossil record
and the facts of science it is true
because sadly Jimmy Aken and Trent horn
both are proponents of theistic
Evolution yep that's why I like sis and
others now if someone wants to tell me I
hold to theistic Evolution but I leave
Adam and Eve were created the way
Genesis says Adam from the dust and Eve
from the side I can tolerate that it's
okay if you believe Adam and Eve were
specially created the way Genesis says
Adam from dust Eve from his side but you
believe everything else God used
Evolution so that Genesis is poetic I
can tolerate that and I can work with
such an individual I can that's just me
but when you're going to tell me myth
history no that to me that's crossing a
line I can't do that okay it's
capitulating too much pretty much you
think it's granting too much of course
because you want to go William Lane
Craig where there was already a group of
species alive that closely resemble
human beings and God selected a couple
from them and Infused a soulen them and
then rewrite Genesis as myth history to
F to fit in with your view get the hell
out of here dude